the war in ukraine now and a southern
ukrainian city is at risk of flooding
after russian forces hit a reservoir dam
nearby officials say the water level on
the river running near the city of
cleveland rose about two and a half
meters after the missile strike some
residents have been asked to evacuate
their homes let's bring in al jazeera's
gabriel elizondo who's in the ukrainian
capital key for us gabe what more are
you hearing about this dam that's been
targeted how significant is this
well we're hearing from the the mayor of
kriviri who's saying that about 100
homes there have been flooded and that
partial evacuations are taking place of
some of the neighborhoods of creveri it
does not appear to be catastrophic
flooding nevertheless it is still
causing serious problems
because this dam
was hit
by several russian missiles late
wednesday evening
causing this inulits river to overflow
its banks and immediately start to flood
the town of kriviri emergency crews
continue to work in the town to try to
mitigate the damage there
but clearly this was a strike
that was clearly did cause significant
damage to the dam but crews are also
trying to repair that damage as quickly
as possible
to try to prevent any further
infrastructure damage or damage to homes
or property in the civilian areas there
now creveria is a city of about 600 000
people and it's about 100 kilometers
north of the southern front line of this
war right now it's unclear exactly why
the russians would want to target this
but perhaps it's because kraviri is a
home town
president baltimore zielinski also
potentially could with the overflooding
of the banks of the river could help in
infringe upon uh ukrainian supply routes
to the southern theater of this war but
we do know clearly that this was a clear
attack on civilian infrastructure right
you're even hearing from the british
ambassador to ukraine that just tweeted
a few minutes ago uh that this was a
clear attack on civilian infrastructure
so so it would seem that the russians
gabe are targeting ukrainian
infrastructure in response to the
ukrainian counter-offensive what's the
latest on that counter-offensive what's
been happening on the battlefield
on the southern offensive the ukrainians
continue their methodical
counter-offensive in the far south in
the herzone region they are receiving uh
getting a lot of resistance from
russians it is not a fast or direct
counter-offensive like what we saw in
the northeast and
what essentially the uh ukrainians are
trying to do is encircle uh large
battalions of russian troops and cut
them off from their supply routes but it
is fierce fighting in the south just
overnight the ukrainians were able to
shoot down at least one russian military
plane and launched at least 13 strikes
against russian military
positions
but this is according to at least one
ukrainian military official i spoke to
fairly recently he said the
counter-offensive in the south could go
on for weeks perhaps even months he said
that is all dependent on one thing and
that is
military arms
sophisticated weapons from the west he
said this the more of that that we get
he said and the faster he said the
faster that this counter offensive can
go on but clearly uh stiff strong
fighting by both sides in the south in
this counter-offensive rehearsal
now while thank you very much for that
gabriel elizondo reporting there live
from ukraine's capital kiev